welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and there the Punisher goes killing
again because John Bernthal has just
been confirmed to return to his role as
Frank Castle mostly because the devil
made him do it Daredevil born again that
is so let's go over everything that we
know about this incredible production
shall we because it is shaping up to be
an exciting one mostly because the
punisher's return in this specific time
in the MCU could be setting up something
really dope that everyone has been
waiting for but like always do not
forget to hit up nerd riot.chop today
we've got gear inspired by the last of
us as you can see on my shirt here we
got a great Steakhouse shirt inspired by
The Last of Us which is quite disgusting
so head on over to nerd Ryan dot shop
today to find one of those for yourself
alright so as I speak these words to you
over the Internet machine one Charles
Cox is being filmed crime fighting
criminals in a Chris new California suit
in Daredevil born again and since this
18 episode production is still active
details about the show have slowly
started to pour out with the biggest and
most exciting piece of news so far being
the confirmation that John Bernthal will
indeed be returning to his role as The
Punisher in this upcoming season of
Daredevil and this is literally the
greatest news ever because Jon Bernthal
and Charlie Cox have such amazing
chemistry in season 2 of Daredevil on
Netflix when the Punisher character was
first introduced but not only this
punisher's introduction into the larger
Marvel Cinematic narrative during this
particular period and the MCU is extra
hyped for another big reason that I will
get into later while Marvel Studios did
manage to secure bernthal's return into
Kevin feige's MCU plans not all of our
favorite faces from Matt's past will be
returning in this upcoming season as
actress eyelid zurer will not be
returning as Vanessa Fitz Wilson's loyal
life partner and the reason why we know
Kingpin is that is most powerful with
the car door in hand
foreign
by actress Tangerine Holt from the hit
series he expands according to the
Hollywood Reporter and it's also been
revealed that both Deborah and wall and
Ellen Henson will not be returning as
Matt's best friends Karen Page and foggy
Nelson in this upcoming season it has
not yet been confirmed if their
characters are being recast but if
Marvel Studios is willing to make a
major recast like Vanessa Fisk Karen and
foggy might just be next Michael
Gandolfini of the many Saints of Newark
will also play a big role in the series
with many speculating him to be playing
Wilson's fisk's son Richard Fitz but
that is not confirmed if so though this
would be the second time we would see
Vanessa and Richard Fisk in a major
Marvel release after those two
characters drove Wilson Fisk to open up
the spiderverse in Sony's into the
spider-verse the greatest Masterpiece of
all time and we also know that it has
been recently confirmed that the first
episode of the series will be directed
by Michael Cuesta known for his
directing and executive producing of
Homeland and we also know that Jill
Blankenship and granya Godfrey two
writers for the CW's arrow and
arrowverse have been signed on to write
some episodes of the series 2 with Chris
ORD and Matt Corman running the show
with their past experience working on
the Beloved Covert Affairs TV series so
needless to say that a writer's room is
stacked and I very much cannot wait to
finally get a peek into what they got
cooking because that Born Again title
has been confusing as hell for a lot of
Daredevil comic book fans and I really
want to know what that subtitle means
for the MCU as you may already know the
Netflix series adapted a lot of the
elements from Frank Miller's 1986
Daredevil Born Again storyline already
like Matt's secret none mother nursing
him back to health and Kingpin learning
Daredevil's identity and getting a
mentally unhitched killer to pretend to
be an adorable so I am very curious as
to what the offices of ORD and Corman
got cooking for us in this season and
look guys I like to live in the now as
in I need energy right now I don't have
time to run to the store to grab coffee
or something so I just pop one of these
a One-Shot energy
um well I feel the energy coming to my
body already Jesus Christ
once your Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everyone really each energy shoe has
75 milligrams of pure caffeine plus 600
milligrams of additional new cropics to
give you a serious energy boost that
works immediately as you chew and man
does it work like as I was chewing that
I felt the alertness and power coursing
through my veins like put it directly
into my veins I say the focus shoes are
great when you need to concentrate and
they give you a natural boost of energy
with BCD and E vitamins plus zinc to
help with immune system support and the
amino acid tyrosine but my favorite
ingredient is the blue raspberry flavor
rasposine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus that you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals and
so get started with one shot energy
today by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order that
is oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for
10 off your order and we think one shot
energy for sponsoring this video and
giving all the viewers the extra shot of
energy that they need to survive and
thrive and be nerdy all the time but
another big question Still Remains will
Daredevil born again be a direct
continuation of the Netflix universe or
is Marvel Studios working on a soft
reboot of the series after securing the
rights to all of their Defenders
characters back from Netflix well there
hasn't been an official word on that
quite yet Vincent D'Onofrio the Kingpin
himself has come out and said for
audiences to expect a sharp distinction
between the two production houses with
Vincent D'Onofrio recently tweeting it's
going to be very very cool very
different from the Netflix show which as
we know was amazing yet this is brand
new and really smart we are going to
surprise everyone with it and at d23
Charlie Cox underscored Kevin feige's
comments on the series being a new
beginning rather than a continuation of
his Netflix narrative in the past I
think that it's the sense is it's going
to be a new beginning it's going to be
different it's going to be tonally
different it's going to be news stories
and new ideas it and and it's just like
Kevin said it's a season one it's not
season four so it's a whole new thing
which is I think the right way to go you
know like if you're gonna do it again
let's do it let's do it differently so
while we cannot see for sure if born
again is a reboot of Netflix's original
series the great news is it kind of
really doesn't matter because we in the
Multiverse Saga baby if Daredevil born
again is Kevin feige's soft reboot of
Netflix's Daredevil Charlie Cox and
Vincent D'Onofrio will likely be playing
their characters exactly the same way
that they would have in the Netflix
Universe because both versions of their
characters very likely experience the
exact same events with slightly
different looking characters just
because Vanessa might look different in
the MCU 616 Universe She very likely
still probably live the exact same life
as Netflix Vanessa it just seems that
Marvel Studios is deeply committed to
doing their own take on the character
while still respecting the character's
history and vibe that Netflix built I
think there's a chance that we can have
both here so even if it's a different
Universe Daredevil because it's the
Multiverse and the Multiverse Saga that
we are in it's basically the very same
Daredevil story that you've known from
Netflix continued on in the MCU universe
that Marvel Studios has built it's a new
universe at the same old Matt Murdock
who went through the same old things but
anyways we have got to talk about the
Punisher again because the possibilities
of the punisher's return to the MCU
during this period should excite
everybody mostly because of the weight
of the Punisher story ended in season
two gives Punisher a direct connection
to the Thunderbolts when we last saw
John Bernthal as The Punisher he was
getting a job offer from the CIA
courtesy of his former battle buddy
Adina madani they're the best
I'm offering you a job Castle
I already got a job madani
care
now with Contessa valve the new Fury of
the Thunderbolts team securing control
of the CIA and the CIA has their eyes on
the Punisher skills I think it is
reasonable to expect the Punisher to be
involved in Val's Thunderbolts which
would be really sick and very comic book
appropriate but only time will tell but
yeah that is basically all we know about
Daredevil Born Again coming to Disney
plus sometime in the spring of 2024.
thank you so much for watching this
video you can follow me at mrertainment
on Twitter if you want to see me tweet
some weird and really fun theories
but most importantly you can follow new
rock stars wherever we are on the social
medias and do not forget to hit up nerd
riot.shop we got some really great stuff
this time around so check that out today
thanks again for spending time with me
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye
foreign